so many goodyear mama's so broke jokes
y'all mamas all broke
she got a sugar daddy I just only know
reality and mom is out there just buying
Kia's what the hell
you alright and now I'm hi Tiffany why
you can have a nice lay down but tell me
what to do I would just be like girl
that's your mama cuz you got think about
it like okay she stayed in that lady for
nine months right she come on with frame
winner for nine months right okay now if
you just go buy a womb okay it's like
$10,000 for the insemination
then what's the price of pregnant and I
think something ten thousand first ten
thousand that was the move in called
absolutely that's the first the last one
it depends on the womb but anywhere
between two and three thousand dollars
and less if the mom had to get a
c-section does that mean the daughter
lost her security deposit on the womb
that part right she messed that baby it
so then she she don't oh my god how to
get it back and damages yes you not get
that you don't get that back got kids
with little homewrecker
[Laughter]
[Music]